we're taking a closer look at southeast
Asia today and how the Russian invasion
of Ukraine so far away is impacting the
region and also how some countries have
responded Asia has seen far fewer people
take to the streets to protest the war
nothing like the hundreds of thousands
who rallied across European capitals
instead most protests have involved
ukrainians and Russians abroad such as
this group in Bali Indonesia
Indonesian president Joko Widodo has
decided not to join the group of Nations
imposing sanctions on Russia in general
the country prefers to stay neutral when
it comes to conflicts in part because
the main domestic agenda is economic
growth and that means doing business
with as many countries as possible
Russia accounts for less than one
percent of trade with Indonesia but
about 16 percent of the country's
military weaponry is from Russia DW's
Georg Mattis had the chance to speak to
Indonesian Ambassador Nira sawajaya
director general for American and
European Affairs you can see how he's
trying to walk the line Ambassador Murad
How concerned are you about the
situation in Ukraine well we've been
very consistent from the beginning
before the war broke up we are already
sending a message that you know
everybody has to use the negotiation
peaceful settlement of dispute and
immediately when the attack began so the
president you know has already been
telling from his uh Twitter that you
know the war will will will not help and
also will end to the suffering of
humanity and that is the reason why we
are participating in the U.N General
Assembly so you mentioned the U.N
resolution for which Indonesia voted to
condemn the Russian invasion yes at what
point would sanctions be something that
Indonesia consider well you know what we
are trying to do is of course to stop
the conflict first and uh address the
humanitarian issues as well as create a
safe passage the safety of the civilians
is very important addressing the issue
of humanitarian is also very crucial and
that should be you know immediate step a
step that we have to take from an Asian
perspective what kind of geopolitical
lessons do you draw from this conflict
well you know very important lesson
first
conflict or military attack will not
resolve the issue will not benefit to
anyone and this is very important number
two the lesson that we learned
negotiation and peaceful settlement of
dispute should be the only options for
people to sit down number three I think
we have uh you know a stated uh many
times International Community is saying
that multilateralism should be upheld
should be strengthened do you think in
terms of world politics this will shift
the focus on the in the Pacific from the
United States for example rather towards
Russia again I hope not you know because
I think the International Community has
to work together in unity you know we
have very important agenda for Humanity
this is already affecting Humanity all
over the world we are talking about
pandemi we need to also collaborate in
unity we need to also address the issue
of economic reform post-pandemic
situations well of course the war should
stop but then you know we should not
also uh you know
forget that the International Community
has a very important agenda that we that
require us to be United to be in the
united front in order to address that
pandemic without that I think it will
keep on going and then it will also
bring uh you know uh you know tremendous
impact to humanity but but certainly I
think the message of the Indonesian
government is very clear the war should
stop Ambassador thank you very much for
your time thank you George thank you
not all countries in Southeast Asia have
stood on the sidelines Singapore often
viewed as Asia's version of Switzerland
surprised many when it decided to join
sanctions the foreign Ministry statement
made clear why quote the sovereignty
political Independence and territorial
Integrity of all countries big and small
must be respected Singapore takes any
violation of these core principles
seriously as they are fundamental to the
survival of Singapore a small state
joining us is Ian Chong associate
professor at the National University of
Singapore with a focus on international
relations in the indo-pacific Ian can
you tell us more about Singapore's
thinking what struck me was the blunt
assessment we're a small country we
worry about big countries
right so for Singapore it's a
long-standing issue about its size we're
small so there's a lot of emphasis on
international law on juridical equality
because the governing a party and in
fact others in society sort of see
having that sort of juridical equality
that protection of sovereignty as a
platform to raise Singapore standing to
give Singapore a sort of equality with
the larger Powers so that's certainly
going to be an emphasis in all all
things that Singapore does so before
when Singapore had to deal with the uh
arbitral tribunal ruling on the South
China Sea it also emphasized these same
sets of principles it's uh quite key to
Singapore's self-understanding and its
positioning internationally
but it's a country that has also
generally avoided taking sides so I
wonder how big a deal is this and do you
get a sense of whether citizens support
the move
right so
given um given the considerations of
size Singapore tends not to want to get
into big fights but because this is seen
um this issue of sovereignty and
international law is seen to be key to
Singapore's own interests so it's not
really taking a side uh apart from
Singapore's own side right so uh in
addition I think uh to the question
about you know how the public sees it
public actually is sort of split on it
there are some who are quite critical
they would rather just avoid any trouble
not say anything especially after Russia
had publicized uh Singapore's a list of
names that of countries that included
Singapore saying that they were
unfriendly to Russia so so there's some
fear of repercussion uh in addition I
think Singapore is talking uh about the
sovereignty issues but it's also
interested in joining the sanctions
because as a financial Hub in Southeast
Asia it probably has more links to
Russia and of course the rest of the
world than its neighbors in that sense
uh Singapore I think would be quite
concerned if any secondary sanctions
came and affected it that would look
really bad for Singapore's credibility
as and as this actor that tries to be an
honest broker that tries to emphasize
the rule of law so he doesn't want to
have that bad PR hit as well so
um I think that's part of the
consideration we can't rule out but of
course it sounds much nicer to talk
about uh these um you know more grounded
broader more abstract Noble even
principles
now we're starting to see how this
conflict will impact the global economy
the price of oil for example how do you
anticipate the global supply chain all
that stuff impacting Singapore
so Singapore even before the conflict
had been experiencing increasing
inflation like many other places of the
world in the world so this current sort
of spike in oil prices also in food
prices is going to hit Singapore I think
uh that the full effects aren't fully
aren't felt yet but they will bite and I
suppose it's a bullet that Singapore
will have to uh bite fortunately
Singapore
um is uh wealthier so it may be able to
you know come up with subsidies and
things like that for its own citizens
um although the slight wrinkle there is
that it also recently passed a goods and
services tax increase so uh some of its
citizens will really feel
um the pressure
um that come with inflation
Ian Chong thank you so much for joining
us
absolutely thank you
the clearest impact the sanctions have
of course is on Russians and that
doesn't just mean those in Russia it
also means those living and working
abroad some have been living in Paradise
in Bali but their situation is turning
into a bit of a nightmare
Constantin Ivanov has savored bali's
warm climate and leisurely Vibe things
less common back home in Russia but
recently the vibe has changed
withdrawing money from his Russian bank
account no longer works
we've been completely stripped of our
finances they've been completely Frozen
and we cannot use our finances at all
here
many Russian banks have been cut off
from the global Swift transaction system
visa and MasterCard services are
suspended and the ruble is in free fall
only a few Russians here still have cash
on hand
recently some Russian clients have
changed their mode of payment
and there's been a decline in the number
of Russian customers
we assumed it's because of the impact
from what's been happening recently and
some of the Russian visitors credit
cards have been blocked
and of course besides all the financial
troubles Constantin Ivanov says he's
concerned about his loved ones back home
nobody wanted this war
we're all really worried
man watching
nobody wants War
we all need peace
we spent time looking at southeast Asia
but we end this
we started with China because of all the
countries in Asia China is the most
important one when it comes to what it
can do about a conflict thousands of
miles away it has not joined sanctions
in fact it has reaffirmed its alliance
with Russia saying its friendship with
Moscow is quote Ironclad at beijing's
annual Congressional meeting on Friday
Premiere Lika Chang delivered this
Anodyne statement
the current situation in Ukraine is
indeed disconcerting
we should do our best to support Russia
and Ukraine to overcome difficulties
conduct ceasefire negotiations and reach
a peaceful outcome
we support and encourage all efforts to
resolve the crisis peacefully the top
priority is to prevent tensions from
escalating or even getting out of
control there is consensus in the
International Community and all parties
for this
China calls for maximum restraint to
prevent a large-scale humanitarian
crisis
China has put forward an initiative to
deal with the humanitarian situation in
Ukraine
and has started and continued to provide
humanitarian assistance to Ukraine
foreign
as this conflict deepens will China
change its position it's something for
us to keep an eye on